une signature qui vaut 10 millions
d'euros fleur pellerin ne s'est pas
déplacé pour rien à bourges en figeant
pour trois ans les aides de l'état la
culture impact culturel c'est son nom
voulue par la ministre sans ses invités
les communes à ne pas sacrifier la
culture sur l'autel des économies sans
c'est aussi confirmé certains grands
équipements comme à bourges la future
maison de la culture
toujours en suspens c'est un engagement
de l'état effectivement à venir a
apporté son soutien au projet de
nouvelle maison de la culture et le
pacte en revanche stabilise les apports
de l'état en fonctionnement pour pour
d'autres projets culturels de la ville
c'est un signe fort qui effectivement
nous bouge encore davantage pour pour
développer ce projet le plus rapidement
possible maintenant arrivés hier soir
fleur pellerin a aussi tenu à rassurer
le monde de la chanson en parcourant les
allées les concerts du printemps de
bourges où ici à l'expo juliette gréco
critiqué pour ses distances avec la
littérature
il sera donc dit que la ministre connaît
la musique
j'ai fait beaucoup de musique classique
enfants et puis adolescente par la
pratique chez tech aux pianistes et
j'aime beaucoup de styles différents et
j'aime beaucoup la programmation que
nous a réservé cette année à daniel
daniel colling qui quitte c'est la tête
du printemps cette année mais le
festival se voit lui conforté par le
pacte culturel de bourges le sixième
signe en france ce matin 40 le seront
d'ici la fin de l'année